à gauche
[Musique]
allez
[Applaudissements]
j'écris
seco j'adore et j'adorerais javel est la
vallée d'olt dallas j'adore bofa a tous
déjà merci merci ca c'etait vous avez
participé c'est ça c'est bon c'est réglé
ils sont payés sont participer mais je
leur fasse une belle époque c'est bon
ils sont payés c'est bon mais c'est bon
les cherry est la vallée de dallas
j'adore toi c'est quoi
on va à l'époque à l'époque quand
écouter la vallée de dada ouais tu étais
persuadé qu'ils étaient donc des to non
mais sans rigoler et rappels ou pas
genre tu te prenais pour un show où tu
vois tu étais en opel kadett tu mettais
la halle a valu le ghana a complété la
route
[Musique]
oh c'est le bon bateau cheminées sont
repartis dans la vallée cela je les
adore rigoler c'est déjà une idée des
faits le loup le renard est là les mecs
il écrivait des chansons et se balader
dans les bois et écrivant son argot
c'est pas la vallée de dana là bas mais
oui mais dis moi il ya toujours un peu
bien sûr je vois pas que le vent souffle
sur les pets de l'âpreté de la
mauritanie showed that are dernier
regard sur ma page mon fils et mon
domaine qui me faisait peur on est venu
me chercher les brides ont décidé de
mener le combat dans la vallée et là
normalement sa règle et vous connaissez
les maires non avant toi tu fais comme
ça moi je bois genre ya des mères des
fois qu'on est maire aujourd'hui je sens
jack welch des coucous fait pas si tu
connaissions si bien que le son qu'elle
re as même quand on est sous l'eau on
peut aller plus bas
c'est pour un récent essai le grand bleu
de l'animation
j'adore maxime suis content que vous
soyez là vous haussez en plus je vous le
dis bravo à cette équipe je vous dis
reconduit aujourd'hui parce qu'on avait
fait un pari on a ici vous faisait
millions vendredi
vous seriez de retour aujourd'hui bravo
à vous ça fait vraiment plaisir d'avoir
une équipe aussi performante et je le
dis aux téléspectateurs ça c'est une
table qui me coûte 30% moins cher 30%
moins cher que d'habitude hanouna avec
cette api s'en met plein les poches
ça tombe par tous les partis qui ont peu
m gd à lui à dalston le directeur
général mais moi les moins chers guy
massé bros quoi quand on a pas comment
la merde voilà donc donc ça donnait ça
c'est des jo les gens avaient fumé mais
c'est qui c'est pour ça que ça marche
en fait c'est le noir singer son masque
ça veut dire toutes les maisons sont des
enquêtes qui sont ces jeunes ou pas
tomber mes choix sont là comme tout cas
pas celle de barack obama de la nomade
vers situation cammas elles font cammas
à huy alors lui tu vois je crois que
jouer les ans sur ton enquête ne savent
pas quelles sont ces gens oui voilà on a
été plus massive doit céder mal qu'on
connaît pas et même quand il enlève tout
ne sais pas c'est pas voilà halal a
annoncé clair aller s'il vous plaît
j'aimerais juste qu'on s'arrête nous
assure seconde parce qu'ils les 19h17
et hier sur isabelle vérification cbg
combien de doigts
est ce que vous êtes bien réveillé lisa
ray mais j'ai vu qu'il y a raconté j'ai
vu qu'ils meurent pendant l'émission
j'avais eu une fois des récentes
acquisitions alors il m'a demandé par m
restez tout savoir que vous vous dormez
devant la télé il salua donne
normalement tu as de la télé satan d'or
tu sais toi tu es tranquille tu vois
avec le sud ouest où ils adorent de
rater les intentions de nantes où il a
faut savoir isales s'endort c'est un
truc de fou
c'est à dire qu'elle croit que tp ça
dure 15 minutes c'est la seule qui
croient que tu es paix rhdp l art match
de foot ouais je sais qu'on est les dix
commandements à la bulle droiture de 400
mais sans regret j'ai pas dit elle croit
que c'est juste une histoire d'amour
alors j'avais vu le bateau qui prend la
halle berry avez vous alors petit a dit
quoi génial hein
airtel pour elle s'appelle carte et
c'est là à dos du retweet en fait mais
ocz à isa merci d'être là et j'ai mis en
place maintenant depuis hier il était
charmant thien quy tac au tac à ma
pierre juste un petit bouton derrière
desquels sont d'anciennes petites
décharges et